OK, let's get down to business.
One announcement: tomorrow will be
weekly quiz number 11 based on
homework 11. And then,
of course Thursday and Friday there
will be no academic exercises in
connection with the Thanksgiving day
holiday. So, last day we started
talking about polymers,
macromolecules.
These are chemicals that have a very
high molecular weight with a
repeating chemical structure.
I've given an example here of vinyl
chloride as the individual molecule.
And, by addition polymerization, we
can break the double bond,
have it propagate, and we end up
with something which is the
polyvinyl chloride.
N numbers can be very large,
and we can get molecular weights in
the vicinity of 1,000,000
grams per mole.
We further looked at tailoring
properties by control of molecular
architecture. We saw that we could
look at bulk composition and form
such things as copolymers,
which are to polymers what alloys
are to metals.
Another way of tailoring properties
is to vary the arrangement of the
side groups on the backbone.
This is the tacticity of the
polymer. And it is to a polymer
what the stereoisomerism is to
individual molecules.
And that lastly,
we looked at the shape of the
backbone itself,
different conformations,
and this is owing to the rotational
capability of the carbon-carbon bond.
And, at the very end of the lecture,
we looked at two forms of formation.
One is addition polymerization,
which is shown here.
We have the three stages.
We start with initiation here.
You see hydrogen peroxide, which
has turned into the radical.
And that triggers this reaction,
which then moves the unpaired
electron to the end here.
And this is sticking out like a hot
poker. And other gas molecules in
this case, ethylene that come in
contact with it will,
in turn, have their double bond
broken, and so on,
and so on. And finally,
we get to the length that we want.
We terminate the reaction, and
that's the end of the process.
The second one was condensation
polymerization.
And condensation polymerization is
stepwise, where you take
two different mer types.
And here's a cartoon showing an
example of the formation of PET.
This is the material that's used
for soda bottles,
and many of the clear plastic
containers that you find in the
supermarket or the drugstore.
So, this one vividly indicates that
it, in fact, is an acid-base
reaction. I said last day,
you had an R1, which is a proton
donor, and an R2,
which is a hydroxyl donor.
Those are classical Arrhenius
definitions.
And so, in this case,
you start with terephthalic acid,
which is basically benzene, with
this carboxylic acid on the end.
The COOH is carboxylic acid. We'll
see that repeatedly.
It's a basic group. Basic is the
wrong term. It's a group intrinsic
to proteins. It's an acidic group.
It's not a basic group. But, basic
meaning a different way.
So, here's terephthalic acid.
Here's ethylene glycol. This is
what you put in your cooling system.
This is the same thing as Prestone
2 Antifreeze.
It's a double alcohol.
It's got hydroxyls at both ends,
it gives up one of those, combines
with the proton here to form water.
And then we form the amide bond,
which then starts the polymer here.
And, it in fact is a polyester
because in the end,
you've got this COO that the O acts
as a bridging oxygen.
So, bridging oxygens we've seen in
silicates, borates,
as critical in covalent network
formation.
And, they are operative here.
When they are operative in polymer
systems, that type of polymer is
termed a polyester because the ester
linkage is this oxygen with a double
bond. So, this is polyethylene
terephthalate,
PET as you know it.
And, the other thing that I wanted
to point out is that if you look
carefully at the structure of these,
last day we studied cross-linking.
And, cross-linking depended upon a
covalent bridge between two chains.
And in this case,
it's typically made with sulfur.
So, we have sulfur attacking
residual double bonds in the
backbone to form single bonds
between backbones.
So, we have two chains linking.
Well, if you look at the features
of the polymers that are made by
condensation polymerization,
you'll notice that in many instances,
I think here's a good one to look at,
Kevlar. You see the carbonyl group
here, the C with the double
bond to the oxygen.
And, on this side,
you have an amino group: nitrogen
with a hydrogen.
And, what can happen is adjacent
chains can hang the aminos on one
side opposite carbonyls from the
other side. And,
look at the situation that we've set
up. Here's the oxygen off the
carbonyl group.
And, it's sitting opposite the
hydrogen off the amino group.
And, you know what that can lead
to: hydrogen bonding.
And so, in many of these
condensation polymers,
nylons, silicones, hydrogen bonding
acts almost as a
pseudo-cross-linking.
It's nowhere near as strong as a
true covalent cross link.
But what we do observe is that the
nylons, Kevlars,
things like this have much,
much higher strength. And, we're
going to learn a little bit later.
They have a higher melting point
owing to this hydrogen bonding.
So, I think we want to just document
that: hydrogen bonding operative in
nylons and silicones.
And, this leads to some additional
strengthening of the material.
Well, what I wanted to do today was
to take up this concept that we
talked about with regard to ordering
versus disordering last day.
We talked about low density
polyethylene versus high density
polyethylene. So,
I want to just revisit influences on
ordering, and actually what favors
crystallization,
factors favoring crystallization.
And, remember, we are not talking
about perfect crystals here.
We're talking about local ordering
over certain lengths of chain which
give rise to some strengthening
of the material.
And so, I'm just going to go back
and revisit one,
two, and three above.
I'm going to ask, how does
composition, how does tacticity,
and how does conformation enhance
crystallization?
So, first thing: let's look at
composition. The way to favorite
crystallization is to make materials
more nearly uniform.
The higher the degree of uniformity
in the polymer,
the greater the chances are that it
can zigzag back and forth and in a
predictable manner,
set up these zones of crystallinity.
So, if this is a straight chain or a
linear chain polymer,
if it's made homogeneous of the same
composition, then the chances of its
folding back and forth on itself and
setting up this local sort of
semi-crystalline region are greater
than if the polymer has some random
variation in composition.
So, the factor that favors
crystallization is having single
composition. So,
homo-polymers are much more easily
crystallized. So,
as an example, polyethylene oxide
can form crystalline polymer,
whereas if you take the polyethylene
oxide, block copolymer with,
say, polypropylene oxide. The
second case is more likely
to be amorphous.
The second factor we want to look at
is tacticity. You've got the three
forms of tacticity: isotactic,
syndiotactic, and atactic. And,
the one that's more readily willing
to pack is going to be isotactic.
So, isotactic version will be
favored from the standpoint
of crystallization.
And, we have evidence that isotactic
polystyrene is highly crystalline.
So, when you see some of these hard
polystyrene containers,
they are predominately isotactic,
whereas atactic polystyrene is
dominantly amorphous.
So, there's the influence of
tacticity. And the third
one is conformation.
How does conformation act?
Well, we've got the linear chains.
We've got branched chains, and
we've got cross-linked chains.
And clearly, following this
paradigm, the linear chains are
favored when it comes to the
formation of ordered structures.
So, if you look at something like
high density polyethylene,
that's shown here, this is the
opaque milk jug.
This has a high degree of linearity
in the chains,
whereas branching or cross-linking
are going to make things very
difficult from the perspective of
forming crystalline structures.
And, in fact, here's something
that's volume versus temperature.
It should remind you of the unit
that we have just covered in
silicate glasses.
We see the cooling curves here at
two different rates.
And, fast cooling as a knee in the
curve at a higher glass transition
temperature than slow cooling.
And, similarly, with fast cooling,
there is a higher degree of quenched
in free volume.
So, all those ideas apply.
The other thing I want to look at
now is on the basis of what we've
seen so far, what are the properties
of polymers? We can tailor things
to a great extent.
But there are certain properties
that they all share.
So, let's document those.
First one: electrical insulators.
Why? Whenever I ask why, we have
to look at electronic structure.
Here, we have strong covalent bonds
up and down the backbone.
And, we have relatively weak van
der Waals bonds with some hydrogen
bonding in between.
In no case are we looking at free
electrons.
So: strong covalent bonds internally.
These are intramolecular bonds,
no free electrons. With covalent
bonds, we have electron sharing and
we have octet stability and the
electrical insularity that
accompanies that.
Second, optically,
optical behavior, while they're
transparent to visible light,
again, the high-strength covalent
bonds transparent to visible light,
and in the case of amorphous, when
amorphous, they are clear.
When amorphous,
they are clear. And,
when we have the semicrystalline
setup, regions of higher atom
density, which translate into
regions of higher refractive index.
And since the refractive indices
are not matched between the
amorphous and the semicrystalline
regime, this acts effectively as an
interface that can scatter light.
So, the semi-crystalline, although
they are formally transparent to
visible light,
these in fact prove to be opaque as
you can see from the appearance
of that milk jug.
Now, the question you've got to ask
is, could you generate
semicrystalline zones that were
either index matched or on a length
scale shorter than that of visible
light? We saw that in the inorganic
case with the difference between
Pyroceram glass and visions.
The only difference was that the
crystallites in visions were
much, much smaller.
And as a result,
we were able to get the
strengthening effect without
incurring the penalty of opacity.
The third one is chemically inert.
Polymers are chemically inert.
Again, the strong covalent bonds,
octet stability, same reasons. And
this leads to their extensive use in
packaging, packaging especially of
foods and beverages.
Foods and beverages exploit this
property. And,
lastly, they are solid at room
temperature. The long molecules,
even though they're only weak van
der Waals bonds operative between
molecules, remember,
the strong covalent bonds are within
the molecule. If you want to ask
the question, is something solid,
liquid, or gas, you have to ask, how
does one molecule bond to another
one of identical composition?
And for that, we got not strong
covalent bonds,
but we've got weak van der Waals
bonds. But, they are operating over
such large contact areas.
These molecules are very,
very long.
So, the long molecule presents a
high surface to volume ratio,
very high surface to volume ratio.
And, that leads to strong bonding.
And ultimately, it leads to
entanglement.
So, we have entanglement.
We have weak van der Waals bonds
over high surface to volume ratio.
And, that leads to solidity at room
temperature. And,
we recognized last day that absent
cross-linking can reprocess these by
reheating. This gives us
thermoplastics that
can be reprocessed.
And even in the case of hydrogen
bonding, although the nylons have to
go slightly higher temperatures.
We are able to reprocess the nylons.
In the case of cross-linking,
of course, we have to go to other
measures because heating to very,
very high temperatures capable of
breaking the cross links would also
break the backbone.
So, these things become not very
easily recyclable.
And, in fact, what I've got here is
the recycle codes which you see on
products today.
The first one is the polyethylene
terephthalate which we just saw the
reaction for. And that's used in
these clear plastics for many of the
things such as,
in this case, it's dishwasher
detergent. The two-liter soda
bottles and so on are this.
High-density polyethylene, that's
this one here.
The next one, V,
is the reaction I showed at the
beginning of the lecture,
polyvinyl chloride. The fourth one
is low density polyethylene,
which is the stretch and seal and so
on. And, I want you to note that
all of these have names associated
with them. And,
these are inventions.
All of these materials that I'm
showing you are inventions of the
modern era. They all came as a
result of research,
patenting, etc. So,
you see this one: 1940, 1951.
These are very,
very recent materials.
Polypropylene: 1951. Polystyrene
technically was isolated by a German
apothecary in 1839 who didn't
realize what he had.
He had some material that he got
out of this resin,
and it was around 1922 when Herman
Staudinger reasoned that in fact
this was as long chain of styrene.
It was polystyrene. He wrote
extensively on it,
and eventually won the Nobel Prize
for it.
Technically, Simon isolated
polystyrene in 1839.
And then, seven is everything else.
So if you see a seven at the bottom,
it's, who knows?
So, that's the chain of events.
So, what I'd like to do now is I
want to show you a few
demonstrations.
And in years past,
I had someone come in here and do
this. But, she has since graduated
and there is a whole bunch of other
factors involved.
So, what I want to do is I've got
some video footage of the
demonstration as it was done.
So, what you're going to see is
several things.
The first thing I'm going to show
you is the synthesis of nylon.
And, this is beaker synthesis of
nylon 6,6. It's condensation
polymerization.
And, we're going to use
hexamethylene diamine.
So, that's the base, and adipic
acid, which is obviously an acid.
So, acid plus base gives water,
plus in this case the
neutralized polymer.
This is only done for demonstration
purposes. In industry,
nylon is not synthesized this way.
They typically go up to around
300。. So, they're going to take
each of these ingredients.
And, they're going to dissolve them
in different solvents.
So, in one case, we're going to
dissolve the hexamethylene diamine
in an aqueous solution,
and then the adipic acid is going to
be dissolved in hexane.
Hexane is aliphatic.
It's nonpolar. It's immiscible
with water. So,
you're going to see two liquid
phases: an aqueous phase and an
organic phase.
So, one ingredient is in an aqueous
phase. The other ingredient is in
the organic phase.
The only place they come in contact
with one another is at the interface.
So, you're going to see nylon
synthesized at the interface between
the two liquids. And,
here's the reaction.
This is Heidi Birch speaking.
[VIDEO BEGINS]
Oh, shut up. [LAUGHTER]
Train your eye right here.
[VIDEO ENDS]
I'm going to show you,
we had a close-up of a previous year
when she did it and we actually had
a camera focused right on the beaker.
So, you get a better scene of the
formation of the nylon.
It's happening right here at the
interface between the hexane and the
aqueous solution.
So, the nylon is forming right here.
And, as soon as the nylon forms,
and seals off the reaction so no
more reactants can get here.
What she does is she pulls this up.
And as she pulls the nylon up, she
exposes fresh interface.
So, everything is occurring at this
interface. It's a self-limiting
reaction. So this next one,
I think, shows it just a little bit
better. [VIDEO PLAYS]
OK, the second one I'm going to show
you is a demonstration of the role
that the glass transition
temperature plays in rubbers.
Rubbers are materials that are
cross-linked. And,
they gain their bounce from the fact
that if you pull on the rubber these
cross links will cause
you to have to recoil.
But if you cool the rubber below the
glass transition temperature,
the entire structure becomes a rigid
solid. And so,
the rubber loses its bounce.
In our lab, if we have to make,
for example, a hole through a rubber
stopper, if you take that rubber
stopper, put it on a drill press and
try to drill, it's very dangerous to
do because the rubber will grip on
to the drill bit.
If you quench the rubber in liquid
nitrogen, take it below its glass
transition temperature,
the rubber behaves as a brittle
solid. And then,
you just drill right through,
get a nice, clean hole, and then the
material heats back up above its
glass transition temperature.
So, Heidi is going to show you two
different rubbers,
one that has a glass transition
temperature above room temperature.
So, room temperature is already
down here, and the rubber ball,
I'm saying in quotation marks, the
ball is going to act like a billiard
ball. It's solid, very poor bounce.
The other one has a glass transition
temperature of negative degrees C.
and so, at room temperature it
bounces well. So,
she's going to, in one case,
heat both of them above the glass
transition temperature,
put them in boiling water.
The other case, she's going to put
them in liquid nitrogen.
So, she'll turn both of them into
solids, and both of
them into liquids.
[VIDEO BEGINS]
He did. He did.
Did you see that?
Pay attention.
[VIDEO ENDS]
OK, the last thing I am going to
show you is something very peculiar
with macromolecules.
I'm going to show you two beakers
that contain liquids that are clear
colorless, but in this case,
green food coloring has been added.
The first one is water. And, when
the propeller spins,
you get a vortex. In the case of
polymers, at low spin rates,
the same thing happens. At a low
spin rate, you'll get a vortex.
At a high spin rate, when the spin
rate goes faster, and
these are liquids.
We are above glass transition
temperature. But if you try to spin
too quickly, you get shear dependent
behavior. It's peculiar with long
chain molecules.
And what happens is,
at very, very high shear rates,
the molecules actually won't slip
fast enough and they essentially
behave as an elastomer.
So, at very high shear rates,
instead of seeing the vortex trough,
you see quite the opposite. And
this is called the Weisenberg effect.
And it has to do with the inability
of the molecules to move quickly
enough over one another.
Let's see what this one looks like.
This is a short one.
[VIDEO BEGINS]
That's water.
So there's the Weisenberg effectct.
And this is a very, very high shear
rates so, the one thing I wish she
had done is turn the speed down.
At a very, very low speeds you
would actually see the vortex form
because you're asking the molecules
to shear over one another in a slow
enough rate that they can keep pace.
So, this is very different from
Newtonian fluids.
This is non-Newtonian flow.
In this, you have to understand if
you're doing such things as
injection molding of polymers
because they do weird things at very,
very high shear rates.
And let's face it,
if you're in business to make money,
you're not going to be gently
plunging the piston into the mold.
You want to pop these things out
quickly. So, there's a lot of
esoteric physics involved.
OK, I'm going to hold that there.
What I want to talk about now for
the last few minutes as the cultural
impact of the advent of polymers.
In fact, many of these come under
the general rubric of synthetics.
These are man-made materials.
These are synthetics. And the real
burst occurred at the dawn of the
20th century. And what I'd like to
talk about is the pattern of
adoption. And this is something
that occurs with other materials,
but certainly in the case of
polymers. At first,
it's wonder. They have these
strange properties that we've seen
some of here. And then,
people go crazy with substitution.
And what we find is that, for
example, the first commercial
polymer was Bakelite.
And, Bakelite was used for such
things as billiard balls,
piano keys, and so on. So you have
what I call the fake everything.
So you have faux ivory, which then
means you can have ivory free
billiard balls,
ivory free piano keys and so on.
With the advent of nylon, you have
fake silk.
And so, you have,
instead of using silk,
silk stockings were a luxury
afforded only by the rich.
With the advent of nylon stockings,
there's a democratization. Price
plummets. Huge social changes take
place. So, all sorts of things take
precedence that previously couldn't
happen. I think I've got some shots
here. This is an ad from something
like a Look magazine.
This is Bakelite.
And if you go to grandma's house,
you may even see some of these large
coffee urns. And the handles on the
side are typically sort of brownish.
These are made of Bakelite. And
it's a phenolic resin that's made by
carbolic acid with formaldehyde.
So, it's a condensation
polymerization.
And, the note the symbol here for
Bakelite. Bakelite,
there's a B with an infinity sign
underneath it, the material
of a thousand uses.
And, these are all substitute parts
that were previously made of metal
or wood now being made of Bakelite.
By now, I mean 1910, 1915. So: big
change. And, plus,
certain parts that used to be made
of metal are now being made of
Bakelite, which is an electrical
insulator. And for electrical
applications in certain instances,
you do not want the ability of that
part to conduct electricity.
So, that's the sort of thing that
takes place. And then,
we have new uses, new products,
new devices.
And then, here's a shot from Fortune
Magazine, 1940,
referring to them as plastics.
And I'll explain why in a second.
But all of these new products,
you've got the telephone here,
fashion, auto parts, footwear, all
of these different things.
There is LP records. You know this
is, but years ago there was an
electromechanical device called a
tone arm with a needle in it.
And it used to play records. Yeah,
well they were made of vinyl.
Actually they were made
of polyvinyl chloride.
And look at this thing here.
You see this thing? That's a film
strip. Photography had been
invented back in the early 1800s.
The mere fact that you can go to
the movies is a result of the advent
of macromolecular chemistry.
Without celluloid, there's no way
you could take glass plates and move
them at 24 frames a second and watch
Star Wars. You just can't do that.
You have to have the ability to put
halide on something that is flexible
and can be made in long strips.
And, there was no material until the
advent of polymers.
Why plastic? The general public
refers to these as plastics.
If I go to Shaws, and I'm checking
out and ask me what kind of bag I
want, sometimes I slip and I say I'd
like the polymer bag.
And they look at me and I say that
one. [LAUGHTER]
So, it comes from the Greek word
meaning to shape.
It's a cognate of the word potter.
So, plastikos really means
something that can be shaped.
And, many of these products are
made by processes that involve
starting with polymer that the shape
is changed. And that's it makes it
so easy to stamp things out.
This is also from the 1940 Fortune
Magazine. This is A Whole New World.
I don't know if you can read this
definition, but here's an
area called cellulose.
There is Nylon Island over here.
There's cast phenolic. I mean, the
whole world: there's the Acrylic
Mountains. Everything is polymer.
I recall seeing in an antique shop
a ladies Waltham watch made here in
Waltham, MA in 1922: platinum case
encrusted with diamonds.
The crystal was made of acrylic.
Acrylic has very poor scratch
resistance, but acrylic was
an advanced material.
And by golly, there were going to
make it out of acrylic.
It's an advanced material.
And it keeps going and going.
Here we are after World War II.
This is Plastics: the Future Has
Arrived. First,
it doesn't look like anything.
It looks like abstract art.
Actually, this is a room.
This is an entire room made of
sprayed polyurethane foam.
This is 1968, people going crazy
over polymers.
But then, people come to their
senses and this book here documents
quite nicely sort of the next stage
which is the chagrin.
And for that I want to take you to
a piece of iconic filmmaking when
people are starting to wonder what's
the real future of polymers?
[VIDEO BEGINS]
This could be you three years from
now. He's just graduated from
college and he's coming home.
[LAUGHTER] That's a young Dustin
Hoffman in 1968.
OK, now this is the scene. Watch.
That's Angela Lansbury.
[VIDEO ENDS]
Well, in point of fact,
that's so ironic. By 1968,
it's not true to say that there was
such a great future in plastics
because people started to realize
the next thing about,
which is the concern. And,
what's the concern? Well, I've
already talked about recycling.
But, there are other concerns.
And they all come from this:
environmental safety and health.
We know about the environmental,
the difficulty to recycle. And,
that's a challenging problem to this
day when it comes to thermosets.
And, even the ones that are
recycled, there's this concept:
recycle as opposed to reuse.
We recycle polyethylene
terephthalate.
But I hope you didn't think that
this goes back on the supermarket
shelves in about 20 days as another
bottle containing dish wash
detergent. There is a
cascade of utility.
So, you start off with something of
high-value, and it gets shredded
maybe as carpet fiber.
Then you end up with something that
could get molded into a park bench.
But, the value keeps going lower,
and lower, and lower.
So, this is still a thorny issue
when it comes to much of polymers.
And then, of course, they are not
degradable in landfill.
Why? Strong covalent bonds.
Very difficult: so that's the E.
And, let's talk about the H -
health. We saw the Weisenberg
effect. In order to facilitate the
processing of polymers,
we add lubricants, what is
effectively a lubricant to enable
the polymer, the long chain
molecules to more easily slip over
one another. And,
these additives are called
plasticizers. So, they
facilitate slip.
And, these are low molecular weight
organics. So,
if they are low molecular weight,
and they are organic, they have
vapor pressure.
They have a very,
very low melting point,
low boiling point. So, they are
volatile. And,
when you are finished processing,
you like to get most of them out.
But, they are embedded inside
macromolecular solids.
And they take time.
That new car smell that you smell,
that's plasticizer. And, you'll
smell it until the last of the
plasticizer is out.
And the trouble with some of these
plasticizers is that they have
structures that are similar to
certain hormones.
And, so they can be ingested and
over certain periods of time could,
I underline could, it's very
difficult to prove direct
cause-and-effect,
but they are becoming increasingly
suspect in genetic disorders.
So down the road,
25 years down the road,
you might find that people who have
been exposed to these could be the
bearers of more tumors than the
general population.
One commonly used one dioctyl
pthalate. This is one of the most
commonly used lubricants.
And, I talked about the
democratization,
the faux silk, giving rise to nylon
stockings for everybody,
but those early pictures of polymers
as this wonder material,
by the time this movie was made,
people were starting to use the term
plastic to be synonymous with cheap,
with shoddy, with junk.
Plastic didn't have the connotation
that it had when the watch with the
acrylic crystal was made.
Things had changed a lot.
And part of it had to do with this
recyclability.
Look at this. This is the annual
production of polymers: about 100
billion pounds,
50 million tons,
and only about three to four million
tons recycled.
And, by recycled I mean returned.
You might ask me, well, why is it
that if you can't reuse this
directly do they make it recyclable?
And, the answer is if this were not
recyclable and the aluminum can is
recyclable, people would not buy
aluminum cans bearing soda.
They would buy only polymer because
they wouldn't want to pay the five
cent deposit. This is human nature.
So, once we decide to recycle any
beverage container we must demand a
five cent, or whatever it is,
deposit is across the board.
Otherwise people will base their
purchases on the one that is least
environmentally friendly because it
doesn't have the deposit on it.
That's a policy issue for you.
Three to four million tons recycled.
Steel, US annual production is 140
million tons, about three times that.
80 million tons is virgin metal,
and about 60 million tons recycled
scrap, a lot of recycling.
Steel is the most recycled material
by far. You might say,
well, what about aluminum?
I heard aluminum was. Yeah,
you heard it from the aluminum
industry. There is 4 million tons
of aluminum capacity in the United
States, about one million
tons recycled.
And most of it is thanks to the used
beverage containers.
But this is a very special
situation because this is made of
three different alloys that were
designed for the environment,
DFE, designed for the environment.
They were chosen, the constituents
of those alloys were chosen to allow
for recycling.
So, they contain only aluminum,
silicon, and magnesium. And these
will melt down and allow to be
reprocessed very, very easily.
But, I like to give the example,
I could take the door off a 1928
model T Ford, throw it into an
electric arc furnace,
melt it down, reshape it,
and put it on a 2005 t-bird,
the same steel. I cannot take the
wing off a McDonnell Douglas DC-3
aircraft, it's aluminum,
melt it down, and put it on
tomorrow's Boeing 777 because
different alloys are used in the top
of the wing and the
bottom of the wing.
One set contains copper aluminum.
The other set contains zinc
aluminum. And when you co-melt that,
you end up with a mix that's neither
fish nor fowl,
and aluminum's reactivity is so
great that to separate the copper
and the zinc is either impossible or
too costly. So,
too costly is equivalent to
impossible, OK?
So, what's the conclusion?
You end up with the virgin metal.
So, I think this is a good place to
stay with these wonderful materials
and I'll see you on Wednesday.